how's it going everybody it's Warren and
last night was the official world
premiere of Avengers endgame and the
reviews are in and they are incredible
now some people were starting to worry
that this movie could not wrap up
everything that has happened in the last
11 years of the MCU some were saying
that it's just too much to fit all into
one movie but the reviews are in and
again it's incredible
nobody has been disappointed with the
movie yet and everybody has nothing but
fantastic things to say about it so I'll
dive into some reviews in this video
there will be no spoilers so you don't
have to worry about that just pure
reviews of how great Avengers endgame
was quick reminder about my Infinity
Gauntlet and glow-in-the-dark famous
painting giveaway if you'd like to enter
all you have to do is be a subscriber
like the video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain so again there will
be no spoilers in this video just simply
talking about the reviews the first one
comes from Brandon Davis over at comic
book calm and he says Avengers in game
is an astonishing amazing film I've
never seen anything like it this movie
is everything I wanted it to be and so
much more amazing he goes on to say
while watching a vendor's in game I
laughed so loud I clapped with so much
force and I cried so hard the movie
exceeds every expectation and is the
perfect culmination of the entire Marvel
Cinematic Universe then we have a review
from Erik Davis who is a managing editor
for Fandango eric says Avengers in game
is a masterful epic a true culmination
of 22 films that not only concludes the
story but expands upon it you'll learn
more about the other movies while this
one unfolds if infinity war is the Braun
in-game is the brains and wow what an
ending over at slash film says imagine
the best possible version of Avengers
endgame and somehow the film still
surpasses all expectations
I cried 5 to 6 times it's the most
emotional most epic MCU film a tribute
to ten years of this universe and holy
the great fanservice in this movie so
good then we have Steve frosty Weintraub
over at Collider and he said don't know
how any Marvel Studios fans walks
of Avengers endgame disappointed the
movie is loaded with incredible set
pieces and tons of small character
moments that leave you wanting more
an epic conclusion to ten years of
Marvel movies thank you to everyone that
worked on MCU and then we also have
Dennis Zeng who is also over at Collider
video saying Avengers in game is filled
with so much comic-book awesomeness that
you may not be ready great blend of
action emotion and humor while keeping
the stakes high throughout truly an
achievement in blockbuster filmmaking
so everyone as you can see Avengers and
game lives up to all the expectations
that we all have all these people are
well respected in the MCU community and
they just say it's amazing as you just
heard and just like Dennis said at
Collider I have heard that this movie
does truly have a lot of links to the
comics and everyone from what I've heard
get ready to cry so that's it for the
reviews again I don't want to say too
much because Avengers endgame hits
theaters throughout the world within the
next few days some lucky people even get
to see it as early as today and tomorrow
I will be seen at Thursday and we'll be
posting my non-spoiler reaction right
after and also if you want to send me
your reaction in an email I'm going to
be posting a fan reaction to Avengers in
game not too long after the film was
released you can send your reaction to
me in the email down in the description
below so let me know how excited you are
for Avengers in game tell me what you're
looking forward to the most in the
comments down below and again a reminder
about my giveaway giving away a
life-sized Infinity Gauntlet and it
glow-in-the-dark painting of fan OHS bye
glow by boat you can also find some of
this other work at glow by beau calm and
the link in the description down below
all you have to do to enter for your
chance to win is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain as always thank you
all so much for watching we're in the
endgame now
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby now
your number